one of the major problems that we have
is that as global citizens we have the
wrong values as global citizens we have
the wrong systems and we have drawn or
like the inner profit institutions and
hence our core business and our agenda
for next 10 years should be about
rethinking our values should be about
redesigning our systems should be about
rebuilding our institutions and if we
are successful one very innovative
product one very innovative development
is if we can come up with a new global
governance system where there's total
buy-in and ownership by all the
countries of the world and this new
global governance system cannot be
business as usual it means we means you
need to rethink redesign and rebuild
United Nations we need to rethink
redesign and rebuild the IMF the World
Bank type institutions in federally to
do away with those institutions and
crafting new ones you cannot solve new
problems by using old solutions all
right but you cannot solve a problem by
using the tools or instruments that led
to the creation of those problems four
hands in the next ten years our target
should be to say how do we accept that
global challenges are in that dependent
how do we accept that global challenges
are interconnected and nations today are
more interdependent that independent how
do we come up with a position that says
you can't resolve the challenges of
climate change in America or Europe
without addressing them in Africa you
can't address HIV and AIDS poverty in
Africa without making sure that is
involvement and participation by all
global players in other words all global
challenges must be addressed in a global
manner meaning global solutions for
global problems and also we must make
sure in this global governance system
Africans become players Africans are
sick and tired of being consumers of
knowledge Africans are sick and tired of
being at the receiving end of ideas we
must make sure Africans and those from
poor countries are participants in the
crafting of the solutions for example is
we address the global financial crisis
West African inputs where is the
addition of Asia of India we must make
sure that we don't resort back to
economic nationalism where America is
looking after America where Europe is
doing the same we must sit down as
global citizens and be able to craft
truly global governance systems where
there's by in an ownership by the
generality of the global community and
this should be a major innovation if we
achieve it in the next ten years